do you have a zero hours contract
and you are completely fed up with your current employer
congratulations
you can probably leave much faster
at your current employer
than you think since the labor market law in balance
is the notice period
for people with a zero hours contract
namely equal to the call term
in many cases it is four days
or sometimes even twenty-four hours
main rule is 4 days
but is a shorter term in your collective labor agreement
has been agreed for the call
for example 24 hours as in the supermarket collective labor agreement
then you can cancel your work within 24 hours
while on
that you do the cancellation neatly in writing
for example via whatsapp or by email